[Music]
oh there we go welcome back to las vegas
now here in this week's la vegas now
segment
our expert eric palacios breaks down
what to do when stopped by police is an
extremely important and timely reminder
take a look
eric welcome back thanks for having me
all right so we're back here again
talking about um what to do when you're
pulled over because unfortunately
you know especially people within the
black community are still so afraid
um of being approached or pulled over by
the police so let's just talk about
what do you do when you're pulled over
it's very important to be respectful and
to not do
anything to make the officers
uh suspicious or uh to think that you're
going to try to flee
or or do something that's a danger to
them so it's always important
if you see sirens and lights you're
being pulled over turn your signal
on your turn signal that way the police
knows he saw me he acknowledges he's
going to pull over as soon as it's okay
to do so when you pull over make sure
it's
hopefully in an area that's well lit and
safe uh turn off the car uh
and put your hands on the steering wheel
uh it's also important to lower your
window about halfway
that allows the officer to talk to you
but it does not allow him to focus head
in or smell
uh what's in your car or to do an
inspection uh which he
should not do okay that's a good
reminder um and
you know sometimes things escalate when
the officer starts asking questions so
do you have to answer the questions
that's a great question you do not the
fifth amendment
uh gives you uh that privilege you don't
have to
talk you don't have to incriminate
yourself you don't have to answer any
questions
that being said most officers are
trained to
just ask rudimentary background
questions
uh where are you going where are you
coming from
do you live close to here who's in the
car with you have you been drinking
uh do you have anything illegal in the
car uh
most of us answer these questions just
out of respect and have it but you do
not have to answer any questions when
you're pulled over
what if the police wants to search the
car
or the vehicle it's another thing that
we see
a lot of officers asking to search the
car without any
probable cause to do so you are allowed
to say
no officer you do not have permission to
search my car
uh and the officer then cannot search
the car if he does search it without
your permission then
we as attorneys can take care of that
further down the line and that evidence
cannot be used against you
okay so then what can we say to the
officers in this moment
most officers will ask you you know why
i pulled you over
uh and again most of the time people
respond you don't even have to
ask answer that question what you should
tell an officer
if you choose to to speak or to say
anything is why am i being pulled over
if he asks if he can search your vehicle
you or
say no i'm not giving you permission to
do so
and then the final question is officer
am i being detained or am i free to go
the officer will then tell you you're
free to go or hold on i'm going to give
you a ticket
but those should be the only
communications that you have with the
police officer
now eric what if they ask you to step
outside your vehicle
well you have to abide by that
and you have to uh step out of your
vehicle if asked to do so
uh again later us as attorneys can see
if that was a legitimate request or if
it wasn't and we can address it at that
time but if you do step out of the
vehicle
be sure to shut your door and lock your
car behind you
that way the officer can't look in the
vehicle go in the vehicle or open it
if you leave the door open or if you
don't lock it the officer can imply that
you gave permission for them to do a
search
so if you're asked to step out of the
vehicle do so close the door
and lock the car all right good to know
we want
civilians and officers to handle these
situations properly moving forward here
all right for more information please
give eric palacios and associates a call
at 702-444-777